three people carried out terrorist
attacks in London on Saturday night a
van rammed pedestrians on London Bridge
stopped three men left the van and went
to borough market I was there not long
ago around New Year's and these three
men started stabbing people seven people
were killed other than the three
attackers roughly fifty people were
injured the three suspects were wearing
fake explosive vests shot dead by police
wearing the fake vest suggests that they
wanted to ultimately be shot dead by
police I don't think anybody will be
surprised at the source of
radicalization here Home Secretary
amber Rudd said that quote we are
confident about the fact that they were
radical Islamist terrorists the way they
were inspired and we need to find out
more about where this radicalization
came from so what happens after one of
these attacks the same the same
predictable things candlelight vigils
and prayers of solidarity with London
which is fine of course as well as
statements that we will not be divided
by the attack then it gets a little more
split you start to see from some the
memes about terror has no religion and
we are all one people and a hesitation
to talk about Islam or if you talk about
Islam you have to talk about how all
religions are equally to blame for
terror which just isn't true any
sensible person realizes that but there
needs to be a serious conversation and I
am NOT talking about a serious
conversation where we just criticize
Muslims at large I am talking
specifically a conversation about Saudi
Arabia and Wahhabism and I know you
might say but David Saudi Arabia and
Isis they don't like each other what the
Saudi Arabia have to do with any
specific attack in a western country for
which Isis is mostly claiming
responsibility well it has a lot to do
with it because Saudi Arabia pours money
into cities like London and that money
does two things one the money buys
influence like for example just days
prior to this terrorist attack in London
it was reported that the UK government
inquiry into the role of Saudi funding
in Saudi money in funding terror
was likely to be shelved in case in
point Jeremy Corbyn claims that Theresa
May the Prime Minister is suppressing
this report about Saudi funding of
extremists so what does that mean well
Saudi Arabia by pouring money into
Western nations including the United
States we're a major major arms deal was
just done with the Trump administration
is going to predispose these Western
nations not to take an aggressive
approach against Saudi Arabia but the
other way that money has an impact is
that Saudi money is used in Europe in
the West to build ultra conservative
mosques and those are incubators of the
ultra right-wing extremist
interpretation of Islam that Saudi
Arabian Wahhabism dictates that is the
model of Islam from the seventh century
which leads to a religious theocracy in
Saudi Arabia that publicly beheads
people for punishment and there is total
and utter subjugation of women where
women being able to drive without male
permission is considered some big
advancement the u.s. the UK have a
relationship with Saudi Arabia that is
really really good for arms
manufacturers and oil companies and
their shareholders but is an immoral one
that is having a depraved and shameful
influence on Western society so it's all
well and good that we're not going to be
divided and we're not going to go out
and harass or attack random Muslims on
the street both would be outrageous but
this pretend game of never truly
standing up to Saudi Arabia is BS and by
the way it's not just the US and the UK
the UN has put Saudi Arabia on the Human
Rights Commission how laughable is that
and it also gives cover to countries
like Iran Iran said yesterday that the
London attacks were a quote wake-up call
and urged Western states to go after
ideological and financial sources of
terrorism in a thinly veiled reference
to Saudi Arabia this makes every Western
nation that is friendly with Saudi
Arabia look like the hypocrites that
they are now as far as you and I should
as far as how you and I should behave in
the context of these attacks in Western
cities these are are horrific atrocities
but don't forget that in large numbers
fortunately terrorists are not hugely
successful they kill a comparatively
small number of people it doesn't make
these events any less tragic but we need
to not kowtow to these incidents by
totally up ending society that's the
important message it's not about oh
nothing to see here there's no problem
whatsoever no there are specific
problems that need to be addressed but
in terms of drastically altering our day
to day lives because of this I know the
whole point is to make us afraid and it
works it works because now you're
wondering hey something's going to
happen at the supermarket or at the
train station or at this concert or on
that bridge or tourist attraction but
you have to not change your day to day
activity as a result of this